non on a entendu dans la voiture tu nous
a bien fait rire c'est que ce truc bien
que tu veux et je dise que je me sens
comme une vieille merde quand je me
regarde dans la glace j'ai envie de
pleurer une star du paf un peu has been
une productrice despotique une gauchiste
altère un peu à l'ouest des youtuber un
peu de b koné visite
l'idole des enfants avec leur dernier
film place publique et leur société en
plus petit les jaoui bacri sont de
retour qu'est ce qu'il faut pas entendre
depuis trente ans les shabaks c'est un
peu le couple incontournable du cinéma
français quand bacri jaoui sont arrivés
dans le cinéma français
ça a été un comme un tremblement de
terre de quelque chose qu'on n'avait pas
encore fait avec le cinéma le couple qui
a réussi à allier humour et intelligence
film d'auteur et succès populaire de la
comédie intelligente donc c'est tout ce
qu'on essaye de faire nous c'est à dire
d'avoir un comédie qui résonne qui
puisse traiter des vrais sujets c'est
quelque chose qui est je dirais pile
dedans
et voilà je crois que ça s'appelle le
talent théâtre cinéma mais surtout
mélange des deux depuis trois décennies
j'avais vacquerie écrivent film scrute
la société française c'est travers
individuel comme collectif géré autorité
sur ces routes on empanne minutes de
cash je dirais plutôt de l'observation
des jeux de pouvoir entre les gens
duo amoureux camaraderie artistique faux
donneur de leçons mais vraie bande à
part qu'est ce que vous faites
j'emmerde qu'est-ce que j'ai pour face
de leurs débuts sur les planches à leur
satire du milieu de la télé en passant
par leur succès en salles
en 2018 les jaoui bacri anti toujours
goût des autres et continue encore à
leur dire je te rends compte qu'ils vont
proposer la carte senior circuler là je
comprends pas ah merci tu découvres côte
à 65 ans tous les jours je découvre tous
les jours
carte senior pour une ambiance fin de
règne dans place publique de jaoui et
bacri pour leur cinquième réalisation
est cette histoire d'animateur sur le
déclin le duo signe un retour en forme
de coup d'oeil dans le rétro c'est
jean-paul là bas j'ai cherché vie comme
ça mon os ou troll de come back pour les
ja bac et peut-être aussi la conscience
de plus en plus prégnante du temps qui
passe
elle est comme exilé du pays de la
jeunesse dans lequel on a toujours
invité donc on le constate depuis la
naissance on est jeunes jusqu'à 50 ans
pour les hommes et 40 enfin je dis ça au
pif a de suite mais battus 2-1 postiches
et presque un sourire en plus
petit sourire puisque je suis en train
de faire
place-publique décline la recette qui a
fait le succès du duo du conflit de la
répartie au milieu jean pierre bacri
dans le cinéma français
un vrai classique c'est quand même le
français râleurs par excellence avec
toute la tendresse qu'il a au fond etc
mais c'est vrai que s'il ya cette
identification c'est parce qu'il
ressemble tellement à la france qui
râlent nos doigts bien c'est juste je
suis en ce moment ça n'a pas aidé il ya
des liens évidemment et qui sont
évidents de film en film et c'est ça
qu'on aime retrouver
c'est ça qu'on sait ça qu'on cherche
c'est quand on va voir ce film place
publique on sait qu'on va prendre en
gros on va prendre un plat qu'on aime
devenu incontournable l'association
jaoui bacri remonte à plus de trente ans
c'était en 87 et sur scène pourquoi nous
et du très vieux jeu
jean michel montabord l'anniversaire
d'un rôle binter et présente jean pierre
bacri et agnès gillot
il y avait quelque chose il y avait deux
pièces dans la pièce il y avait la pièce
de pintor il y avait la piège de comptes
suivent et que leur approche comment il
allait finalement se séduire pas séduit
est resté assez très très gentil très
touchant je pense que jean pierre à
apporter une espèce de de liberté de son
teddy de folie etc
agnès et agnès su apporter une capacité
à la réflexion parce que la nièce je
crois que c'est quelqu'un là là là j'ai
pas combien psychanalyste dans sa
famille et c'est assez bas pour ça
qu'elle a l'esprit de sérieux mais il ya
quelque chose qui se fait de la tijania
discours ce qui les a réunis c'est le
cadre ce qui les a rendus indémodable
c'est au cip le théâtre
cuisine et dépendances un air de famille
écrite au début des années 90 un quart
de siècle plus tard lors deux premières
pièces tombent toujours des gens ta
femme si je peux me permettre une
prouesse mais aussi un savoir faire pas
de scénariste et dialoguiste précieuse
pour le passage à la réalisation ses
enfants l'enfance est pénible gj
sollicite tout le temps des peines
second bateau associés abrutissant tuera
peut-être mais il faudra une chose jeudi
dressage pro c'est chiant pas dû
reconstruire
ils ont montré que le cinéma était aussi
un endroit où le dialogue la parole
était quelque chose qui compte est fait
il du nom du passage où j'ai appris
c'est merveilleux
la tranquillité c6 les c6 laisser précis
ses rythmes et ses pesé c'est chez les
ja oui bacri l'exigence ne concerne pas
que les dialogues
elle s'applique à une manière de
travailler ensemble et avec tout le
monde
depuis leurs débuts au théâtre et
jusqu'au film choral chez eux la
répartition quasi égalitaire des rôles
c'est aussi de la politique
ils ont établi un code déontologique qui
était en effet sur ce métier sur ce
qu'il fallait faire
comment traiter les gens qui étaient en
effet quelque chose d'un partage de
valeurs comme acteur vous sentez
extrêmement frustré quand vous avez
trois scènes dans une pièce vous savez
que vous arrivez à au premier acte d'une
scène au deuxième de petites scènes et
puis à la fin et c'est de brousse à dire
quand on a écrit cuisiner à notre
famille où il y avait cinq ou six
personnages qui était absolument ego et
on a continué à faire ça parce que ça
nous plaît
al'inverse l'univers déjà bac et
fragmentaire il traverse différentes
castes et met en scène un seul et même
rituel
la lutte des classes l'idée représenter
la société tout en filmant à hauteur
d'homme ces endroits où mon père mon
père
j'ai fait pour un serveur dans les
multiples thèmes qu'on continue cause et
il ya le déterminisme la difficulté de
sortir de son milieu justement mais
voilà moi j'adore dans la vie de deviner
quel métier fait telle ou telle personne
et qu'elle casse sociale existe toujours
avec ça nous ça nous amuse ça nous
intéresse de les confronter
si claude sautet a su immortaliser la
france des années 70
jaoui et bacri sont devenus les
chroniqueurs des années 2000 si vous
voulez on va pas du tout la france
paraît peut-être qu'on n'avait jamais
parlé avec autant de discernement
autant de d'acuité autant de tendresse
aussi de cette lutte des classes de ces
beaufs aussi ou de ces gens que l'on
montrait du doigt que l'on considérait
comme des beaufs ya toujours cette cette
envie d'aller parler de ce qu'on voit
peu dans les films de sauter il ya
toujours des gens qui sont artisans
servi dans des cas d être ya toujours
les deux mondes un peu qui ce qui se
côtoient dans les films de bacri jaoui
on a tout le temps le le patron qui avec
son chauffeur et son garde du corps
ils ont une façon de faire cohabiter
plusieurs mondes là dans un seul espace
problème comment être toujours en phase
malgré le temps qui passe
comment ne pas passer deux chroniqueurs
à caricaturiste le caricature c'est une
façon fasciste de raconter un défaut par
exemple dans leur dernier film et grâce
à une bande de youtube heures les
millennials s'intègre la place publique
déjà bac une mise à jour pas vraiment de
la sociologie et peut-être de la
prudence
on a souvent du mal à écrire sur des
catégories sociales connais pas du tout
ou sur des gens qu'on connaît pas du
tout on a besoin de connaître nos
personnages de comprendre
psychologiquement comment il fonctionne
pour pouvoir en parler à partir de la
pop lui car je vois la vraie bande à
part mais jamais or seuls les ja bas
comptent encore visiblement le goût des
autres
merci c'est bon droit michel quand on
veut quand on veut
je suis à filmer la non non j'ai pas pu
tenir